I actually sort out the round of Marie
Colvin in a private war I heard that
they were making a film about Marie I
read a Vanity Fair article that was
written about her maybe a year and a
year and a half after her tragic death
in Syria and the article just struck me
with the kind of the commitment of this
woman the contradictions of her the
passion with which she pursued her
career the single-mindedness but also
this person who was so F S&T optimistic
I suppose despite all the trauma that
she witnessed and I just thought this is
an extraordinary person and if the right
filmmaker comes on to direct the film
then it could be an extraordinary film
and when I heard that Matthew Hyneman
whose background is in documentary was
going to be the filmmaker I just really
really wanted to be involved because I
thought he's gonna have an unflinching
eye on this woman and we're going to get
all of her and there's going to be a
truce to the war zone depictions which
you know really matters it can't be a
Hollywood ization when you're dealing
with subject much like this so I tried
to meet him and I and it took me about a
year to actually to actually meet him
face to face but luckily he was working
on the script for that long so the delay
didn't matter we really hit it off it
was a kind of meeting of minds and I
sort of searched for the same truth and
and he was probably being persuaded and
people were probably trying to persuade
him to cast someone else but we we just
sort of knew we had the same vision in
mind and and and that sort of trust that
we established on that day or an
instinct for the trust that we could
have just carried us through the movie
Marie's great ally towards the end of
her life was her photographer Paul
Kohner and Marie had a reputation for
for ditching photographers who she
became impatient with and Paul Conroy
was one of the few who kind of stayed
the course and you know I think that was
largely because they shared this
fantastic sense of humor and they both
like to kind of go against the grain and
not follow
pack and Jamie Dornan plays Paul in our
film and the interesting thing is when I
came on board the film we didn't
actually have life rights to anybody
apart from Murray herself so other
characters names were changed and then
as people got to know Matthew Hyneman
and and me and we gain people's trust
more and more people said okay I think
it would be great if you use my name so
that was true of Sean Ryan the editor of
The Sunday Times and of Paul Conroy and
Paul Conroy came on board actually as an
advisor and he came out to visit us
during our first week of filming in
Jordan and then he never left I think he
found a kind of like another family
really in the tribe that we become when
we're making a film and I think it had a
sort of strange relationship to them to
the band of journalists on the road
following conflict and I think it was
something in the experience of making a
film that he recognized and felt very
comfortable with so we benefited from
his stories his experiences you know
when we were depicting a scene he was
actually there so the level of accurate
accuracy that he could help us achieve
was astonishing I think Matthew Hyneman
and my greatest fear when embarking on
this project was you know would we be
able to get as close to something that
felt truthful as we wanted to you know
when we were depicting conflict zones
could they feel real could could the
experience that the audience was going
to get come anywhere close to the
experience that Murray had when she was
in these places and I think the fact
that matt has you know shot
documentaries up to this point you know
he's been the cameraman he's taken his
own sound he's he's embedded with people
very much in the way that Murray did to
get to the truth of the stories that
he's telling and and he he followed a
kind of similar instinct with our film
so we filmed all the war zones in Jordan
but he interviewed everybody who was
going to make up the background of our
film so basically whatever conflict zone
we're covering we went we for Jordan
Jordan stood in for Libya Iraq
Afghanistan Sri Lanka and Syria and Matt
found refugees from all those countries
currently living in Jordan and they
became
the fabric of our of the war zones as we
showed them in the movie so when I'm
interviewing people or coming across
people or interacting with anyone who's
been you know the victim of an IUD
explosion or you know people who are
crowding around a mass grave site that
Marie had an instinct about and she
hired a digger to dig up the earth and
they did find bodies the people cried
were on the grace that we were in a
clinic in the besieged city of Homs
everybody was someone who had had a very
similar experience if not the very
experience that we were describing so
there was a level of reality that I just
didn't believe could be achieved really
and it became it became the kind of
touchstone of our film it's what gives
it its true that what it's what gives
its its fierceness it's what gives it
its power because again and again you're
diving into an experience through these
people that doesn't just feel real it is
it is real so you know for instance
there are two women at one point tell me
the stories of you know losing their
husbands and one telling the story of
losing her child and I'd never heard it
until the minute it's told to me on film
and that's the moment that's in that's
in the movie and and it was it's
harrowing and it's harrowing for the
audience it was harrowing for me and I
think comes very close to the kind of
in-depth connect connection driven
reporting that Maria was famous for I
mean I think I'm still very affected by
Marie I I think she's in me somewhere I
think my eyes have been opened to the
world as she saw it you know you you you
inhabit someone your your job as an
actress to trick your brain into
believing you are the person you know
and and if you trick your brain well
enough your body starts to respond as if
you are that person you know so
situations that are not dangerous
because you're an actor and it's an
we are read by your body as dangerous
and your heart will race your sweat
you'll you'll have a physiological
reaction that's not of your making you
know and and and that those experiences
in the body never leave you I think I
mean there is so much pressure in
playing a real person especially someone
who was as fiercely loved and missed as
Murray
I mean how Murray's friends are devoted
her family you know it's it's a painful
recent loss for them her family are
fighting at the moment they're bringing
a court case against the Syrian regime
for Marie's murder they really believe
and have a body of evidence to support
the fact that she was targeted by the
Assad regime when she was when she went
into homes I mean it was an enormous
pressure because because in this
instance and I don't think it's the same
with every real person you play
sometimes I think you can have a
legitimate choice as an actor to get a
feeling of the person across or tell the
truth of their story but not you know
embody them fully but in this III had a
documentary maker as my director who is
used solely to trading in the truth in
real people in observing real people and
secondly I found Marie such an
intoxicating woman when I listened to
her watched that I just thought I want
to put that on screen I want to be as
close as I possibly can to her I want to
be her I want to apologize for not being
her you know with a documentary maker as
my director so I just tried to do
everything I could to kind of eradicate
all trace of my own instincts and
behaviors and once I decided to do that
I then realized what a what a momentous
task it was you know to change a voice
change your posture change the way you
walk change change the little tells the
little insecurities that you know you
default to in an uncomfortable situation
learn to smoke and that's just the
external there's a whole world of
internal stuff too of course
one of my heroes I ended up playing
right after I played Marie Colvin and
that was Marie Curie so I had this very
extraordinary year where two very
important Marie's came into my hands at
the same time and that was you know they
definitely influence one another in my
mind I think because I was I was sort of
thinking about them both in tandem
sometimes and Marie Curie was just an
astonishing person again someone who
lived courageously
I mean Marie Curie probably I would say
lived pretty fearless Lee Marie Colvin I
don't think was fearless
you know that's often the cliche about
the war correspondent is that they're
fearless I think she was not Phyllis at
all I think she had tremendous fear but
the need to tell the story was so urgent
that she went past her fear apart from
that there's no one there's no one
currently calling me no but give me a
year
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]